we've all gotten lost in the store  before it's strange a little  embarrassing but really nothing to worry  about unless the store you've gotten  lost in is scp-3008  also known as the infinite ikea this  cursed ikea can be accessed through a  kind of portal in a particular but  unknown ikea superstore you can wander  through it without even knowing and then  become hopelessly lost in a maze of  affordable swedish appliances but it's  not just getting lost you have to worry  about the infinite ikea is filled with  tall faceless humanoid entities dressed  in ikea uniforms these monsters referred  to as the staff begin hunting anyone  still trapped in the store when the  lights go off at night thankfully you'll  at least have some company so many  people have become trapped in the ikea  over the years that whole tribes and  communities have formed inside so you  might as well make some friends and  enjoy some meatballs until you can  escape